[Musique]
j'ai mis
ça dans votre samedi soir bonsoir avec
nous ce soir 4 terriens de choix
virginie elfira
la virgine efira et géraldine nakache
bon soit il est ici ce soir pour la
sortie du film et ta soeur un film
français de science fiction
bah ouais un film où vous êtes soeur sur
les quatre mandats sciences inc alors on
est tenu sa demi-soeur accord laurent
david
bonsoir bonsoir thierry alors l'on jette
ici ce soir pour votre livre oui pour
votre pièce et ce petit problème
d'herpès au bout d'eux habite mais
bon on n'est pas obligé d'en parler
autres terriens invité ce soir celui qui
en ce moment a beaucoup de mal à trouver
un vendeur quand il rentre dans un
magasin pour acheter un tee shirt
proches
en p3 après les accus et stéphane
guillon nous accueillons notre terriens
du samedi 20 heures ce soir ludwig
bryant
20 ans après le triomphe d'un indien on
l'a vu l'hémicycle nous racontera ce
qu'il est
voilà une chance à peine salut les
terriens et le groupe les gréements de
chantier
[Musique]
et maintenant voici ta ville
il est
m
bon il veut pas rentrer samedi là
[Applaudissements]
merci tout va bien ça ah oui c'est mieux
alors tabakh monde va bien qu'un bon
soir alors là voilà bravo thierry parce
que là le plateau il a de la gueule ma
prof baffie on a très jolie fille aussi
virginie efira géraldine nakache tu as
eu la chance trouvent parce que la
semaine dernière il y avait une brune
une blonde aussi mais c'était giesbert
et beigbeder savait pas la même gueule
alors virginie et géraldine vous jouez
deux demi soeurs dans le film et à
seurre de marion vernoux alors c'est
dommage que ça soit pas dans un film
d'abdellatif kechiche parce que vous
auriez toujours été demi soeur mais
lesbiennes et incestueuse et là c'était
un césar assuré pour vous deux est à
seurre c'est le remake français de ma
meilleure amie sa soeur et moi on aime
bien faire des remakes en france et on
avait fait corriger les bugs en france s
adonnaient cache avec jean dujardin fast
and furious a donné les clefs de bagnole
de laurent baffie
laurent je suis très impressionné d'être
à côté de lui ça reste un petit peu
comme le le pape devant jésus ou alain
delon devant alain delon je suis très
impressionné non mais c'est vrai c'est
le patron c'est le snipers tireurs
d'élite jamais tirs de sommation
toujours entre les deux yeux c'est non
et c'est là c'est notre meilleur soldat
tu commence une phrase et la termine
c'est l'histoire d'une [ __ ] et d'un
chameau vas-y laurent à toi
[Musique]
ardisson et baffie réunis en plus un peu
les les peter est stone de la télé c'est
vrai besoin de rien envie d'une vanne
est alors toute la dream team et là il
manque juste sorti alors c'est pas qu'il
n'a pas là en taule oui exactement le
juge d'application des peines n'a pas
voulu qu'ils viennent voilà exactement
leur anglais venaient pour un livre vous
avez fait plus de 1800 anagramme way et
d'ailleurs vous avez été accusé de
plagiat par raphaël enthoven il vous
accuse d'avoir repris plus de 40
anagramme d'un autre livre elle rentre
sur 1800 dans mes 40 sur 1800 remarquer
c'était quand même plus rapide de
compter les anagrammes en commun que les
ex de son ex carla bruni donc c'est
logique bien d'accord
[Musique]
alors mon corps réagit pas une anagramme
quand on cherche on trouve alors que
jamais oui on pleasure of rock je le
kiffe ça m'a fait aimer le rap c'est le
rappeur en activité qui a vendu le plus
d'albums en france seraient près de
vingt ans de carrière 2002 nous n'avons
pas deux millions d'albums vendus en
fait pas derrière
alors si j'ai présenté mon public toit
des cas touchent pas parce que je vais
t'éclater
[Applaudissements]
après
off c'est un nos meilleurs rappeurs
selon skyrock c'est une petite
baltringue selon guba alors leur bus
pour expliquer aux téléspectateurs
ça fait trois ans que vous êtes en clash
avec booba c'est un autre rappeur par
exemple pour resituer pour mes
grands-parents qui qui regardent et qui
comprenne bien c'est un peu comme si
marcel amont est en guerre avec lui
offrait
prof c'est c'est devenu un youtube
heures il fait des vidéos sur sa vie un
petit peu comme norman fiset norman fait
des vidéos il fait des vidéos sur ses ex
avec son chat rohff aussi avec ses
expériences de vie à lui aussi comment
couper son bracelet électronique
la vie après la tôle
te lèves pas trop quand même ce sang qui
s'écoule mesdames et messieurs je suis
ici pour vous poser les questions trop
con que thierry ardisson ici présent n'a
pas voulu vos pauses et géraldine
nakache c'était quoi le plus dur dans le
film jouant en bretagne en plein hiver
on faire quoi que vous êtes soeur avec
virginie à ce point
je me sens très blonde -
rohff vous avez déclaré dans vos
chansons ben voila vous parlez de de la
rue de la famille des sentiments de
l'amitié ça fait quoi d'avoir les mêmes
sujets que luan
thierry des émissions
six
étages votre vie si la semaine prochaine
d'ici là au théâtre de la polo
[Applaudissements]
elles sont au top virginie efira et
géraldine nakache
[Musique]
virgin jezira géraldine nakache renoncer
je suis ravie jamais nulle et demi les
costumes de noël
alors vous êtes un exemple de
reconversion réussie toutes les deux
être passé la télévision au cinéma avec
succès plus personne ne se souvient de
vos émissions tant mieux
j'en ai moi j'adorais la nouvelle fois
bas mot su wei un problème que j'adorais
le problème si tu me dis ça comme si
c'était normal d'avoir un truc très très
honteux non moi parce que ça n'avait pas
l'air d'être une interrogation
vous avez fait ensemble canal presque à
tous les deux oui géraldine a déclaré
que c'était une émission naufrage et
virginie a expliqué qu'elle était
obligée de demander aux gens du public
de rire oui ça vient de chez souvent
tard oui je me souviens d'un article
avait été écrit je danse je sais plus
quel journal et le journaliste disant
regarde cette émission comme on regarde
un accident de la route
voilà télévision j'ai touché au cinéma
vous êtes resté dans des métiers où il
ya du sexe et de la drogue on voulait
une cohérence alors les filles le film
qui vous amène sortira le 13 janvier une
fois que tout le monde aura vu star wars
bonne idée savine marion vernoux avec
vous deux et grégoire ludique le mec du
palmashow vrai par le pitch pierrick le
mec du palmashow vient de perdre son
père il est très déprimé son ami tessin
géraldine lui propose d'aller se reposer
dans une maison en bretagne mais là il
tombe sur vous virginie marie non la
soeur de tessa qui est lesbienne mais
vous coucher quand même avec lui
il se passe un truc
voilà vous essayer tous les deux voilà
le lendemain tu es ça arrive dans cette
maison en bretagne vous lui dites rien
niveau nick eric jusqu'à ce qu'elle vous
avoue être amoureuse de pierry vous
savez que ça ferait un scénario de film
porno est patent
on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
je sais que tu es triste moi aussi je
suis triste vas-y moi ce que je dois sur
ok je te fais une proposition
je t'envoie la zone militaire
franchement c'est magnifique quand une
magnifique tu veux dire froid et humide
[Musique]
non pardon pierrick j'ai un pote de
tessa
femmes sur des ballades personnes
malades bail est ce que je peux voir ma
chambre c'est quand même ouf comme un
meilleur ami sur la demi soeur quand
même dit numérique en mains comme l'a
décrite grosse et moche
oui oui oui tu veux dire que si j'avais
pété lesbiennes tu m'aurais bien mais
j'ai un petit quoi je sais pas
venu à nuit
ou [ __ ]
t'es d'accord mais pour qu'elle ne sache
jamais ma belle je ne vais pas rester au
chaud qui avait justement c'est un petit
soirée
[Musique]
non j'ai une prothèse la soeur moi je
suis son meilleur ami témoin conseillère
soir
et aurait fait plaisir de voir comme ça
va tu vas pouvoir avoir un enfant 10 e
position
j'aime bien lire et pourquoi
je
parce que je crois que c'est un mode de
vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
verseur un peu comme dans jumeaux arnold
schwarzenneger et danny devito
alors virginie c'est difficile de
rentrer dans le rôle de soeur de
géraldine nakache vous est gavé de
falafel pendant trois mois
à l'autre et bah ouais ouais je vais
ramener de la salade quid de ma mère tu
vois
dedans et pour devenir lesbienne vous
avez fait comment vous êtes mis au
tennis
va justement ya pas une manière de faire
vous voulez vraiment éviter toute la
folklorisation que ça pouvait ouais
enfin comme s'il y avait un archétype
rien ou quoi forcément après la bimbo la
milf la cougar vous est lesbienne j'ai
décidé d'incarner tous les fantasmes des
mecs comme ça mais à quand je vous
entends comme ça j'ai l'impression
d'avoir une filmographie extrêmement et
érotique sa séduction alors que je fais
des j'ai fait quand même des choses où
c'était mais moi je n'en fais tout ça
existe très peu quoi ans géraldine vous
dans le film vous êtes amoureuse de
grégoire ludique le mec du palmashow
vous avez déclaré il a quelque chose de
très spécial à l'écran il a un côté
masse au grand coeur il n'y a pas des
tonnes d'acteurs comme lui en france ja
c'est un bon acteur
pour jouer un mec savez le pierrick
mais c'est vrai je trouve que grégory la
une il a une enveloppe comme ça grave
pour elle pour un trentenaire c'est pas
le petit trentenaire chétif c'est sur un
fatigué
voilà c'est pas yann barthès et du coup
les hypers entourant comme ça et tu sais
que c'est vous c'est ce genre de
personnage que j'aime bien vos rosiers
rassurant c'est un amour ouais on a
envie de se mettre contre lui un mois
aussi
c'était la
bienvenue
[Musique]
art
vraiment soir les call options lui tint
sommes de retour sur terre tout vous
en compagnie de virginie efira
elong mbassi et droite
virginie et gérard je ne sais pas si
vous êtes au courant mais un sondage qui
vient de sortir c'est sur les actrices
par exemple une actrice sur de rêve de
coucher pour de vrai avec son partenaire
de cinéma entre vous deux c'est là
qu'elle
ça s'est bien passé ton puis méga la
baule
[Rires]
moi je pense que c'est bien de quand
même de privilégier une forme de tension
érotique et dur ou de ne pas succomber à
l'envi alors peut-être l'envié oui mais
il faut pas la concrétiser si tournage
quoi voilà il faut attendre pareil pour
vous mais moi j'attends la promo
on va continuer sur un plateau de cinéma
[Musique]
une actrice sur deux s'est fait faire
des injections de botox entre vous deux
c'est là qu'elle
c'est vrai que 19 ans et j'en ai
moi-même 22 questions ça profite elle
fut parfois je me souviens quand j'ai vu
le fait que le film dans lequel on est
je voyais les plis sur mon visage avons
envie de faire des piqûres à l'écran
après donc mais bon ça va venir ça
viendra une actrice sur deux s'est fait
refaire les seins entre vous deux c'est
là qu'elle guérit oui c'est une actrice
et refaire un sain sur d'autres
une actrice sur deux s'est fait draguer
par françois hollande entrevue
j'ai pas eu cette chance bon moi j'ai
rencontré une seule fois avant qu'il
soit président dans un dîner il était
avec valérie trierweiler donc on peut
pas dire qu'ils règlent beaucoup non
une actrice sur deux étant louboutin
entre bidon c'est là que
[Applaudissements]
une actrice sur deux préfère ne pas
parler de sa vie privée entre vous deux
c'est là qu'un non j'y tiens parce pas
très intéressant c'est une actrice sur
deux clitoridienne enchères
une actrice sur deux a fait une sex tape
jamais fait de ces experts externes
flux de secteur m'a récemment là
franchement je crois pour le boss du
film centré nexans une actrice sur de
même bien entre vous deux sénateurs
si tu l'as dit dans une interview alors
que moi ouais on se connait mois
[Musique]
entre terriens invité ce soir la fierté
de vitry-sur-seine la personnalité la
plus célèbre de la ville celui dont le
nom sera donné un jour à une école à une
bibliothèque ou un théâtre rohff
[Musique]
alors hop bonsoir soit la meilleure
façon de vous présenter c'est ça
oh
il ya ça
[Musique]
et voilà un
certain monsieur 2 millions d'albums
vendus bravo bravo à la ronde c'est
entre les rappeurs c'est un peu comme
entre les boxeurs où les animateurs de
télévision c'est la guerre la guerre des
mots n'arrêtait pas de vous clashé avec
booba pourquoi vous ne prenez pas à
patrick bruel
qui t'aiment pas invité j'en viens à
grenoble mais alors c'est la guerre
entre vous il ya un tweet terrible avec
booba la regarder l'un des mecs y vont
fort c'est assez booba qui est en train
d'écraser la tête d'eurofins
pas défaut pourra le faire en réalité le
fait à travers des photos montages ou
bah si tu veux venir des gens qui même
si d'après lui par les bots ou bah
si tu veux venir expliquer ici
alors en avril 2014
suite à la diffusion par vous d'une
parodie de booba booba répond il est où
le gangster qui règle pas ses comptes
sur le net trouve moi à paname salle
pédales c'est vrai franchement je sais
pas je savais pas ça
c'est nul c'est nul alors là le 21 avril
2014 vous rendez avec quelques potes
dans une boutique en quête qui est la
marque de streetwear de booba
pensiez vraiment je lui ai trouvé booba
dans son magasin en sera une silhouette
d'une c'est pas des potes un cd gens de
châtelet 2
ce qui a pu se passer ce jour là les
rien de prémédité parce qu'il ya une
boutique distincts qui est pas loin en
travaux ouais ça se passe entre deux
dates 2 et de zénith gens plein pour les
élites donc j'ai aucun intérêt à me
retrouver dans cette histoire là bon
voilà je suis entré dans cette boutique
et il n'y avait pas de la taille
et poids ma taille et il a pu redresser
au vendeur
poliment je vais demander qui il était
et puis puis ses saveurs que je me suis
emporté parce qu'il ya eu des fuites
ou on a montré qu'on a donné mon adresse
familiale où il ya eu des photos de la
rue où j'habite donc ça a dépassé le
cadre musical et ça vient de cette
personne qui la baston
après j'ai pas pu maîtriser tout ce qui
s'est passé je me suis emporté c'est pas
très exemplaire ce qui s'est passé mais
vraiment pas exemplaires mais je suis
pas fier cette affaire payé sa dette à
la société maintenant c'est fini voilà
deux employés brutalisé un qui souffre
d'un traumatisme crânien qui perd
connaissance et là vous allez vous
livrer à la police
[Musique]
n est en sus
est-ce qu'en prison ils nous ont obligés
à écouter des albums de booba peuvent
pas tous les étages écoute du rov alors
booba a déclaré chercher booba dans une
boutique uncut c'est comme chercher
ronald chez mcdonald's
c'est l'urne tu
avoues été incarcéré à fresnes vous êtes
libérés deux mois après après paiement
d'une caution par samuel eto'o le
footballeur sympa ouais il a appris la
nouvelle et puis l'envoyer 5 où la règle
est jeune très jeune samuel c'est un bon
gars sang bong samuel eto'o il va au
cameroun il s'arrête au feu rouge il
donne de l'argent c'est vraiment un mec
généreux vraiment sérieusement généreux
enfin bon ils payent la caution vous
sortez vous serez quand même soumis à
deux mois de prison et 17 mois de
liberté conditionnelle avec un bracelet
électronique
alors justement parlons de ce bracelet
électronique moi j'en ai jamais eu je
sais pas ce que c'est dsk y en a sur la
[ __ ]
c'est pas pratique un drap vous dites
parfois tu sors de la douche tu vois le
bracelet et tu réalises que tu es sous
scellés que la justice te tiens c'est un
truc qui vous ronge de cerveau quoi les
quatre premiers mois s est passé comme
ça français habitués ouais mais j'étais
vachement restreint ouais dans mon
travail je vis des manques à gagner
forcément
et en même temps ça m'a permis de me
rapprocher de la famille veut gosse il
joue avec le bracelet électronique des
fois il faut débrancher tout de suite à
fresnes ils voient qu'ils l'ont
débranchée
m'appelle son téléphone puis je dis non
c'est le petit qui joue avec qui elle a
débranché et même des fois quand et sous
sous la couette c est trop épaisse et
les chaussettes ils reconnaissent pas le
radar te reconnais plus il appelle à
l'aide et j'arrivais alors booba a
déclaré des boucles d'oreilles
électronique c'aurait été plus élégant
pour le soir
moi j'ai pas de bouton orange pour pas
ça ouais lui oui
alors vous avez sorti un téléphone danew
byron voilà qui à daniel von rohr est ce
que vous avez pas sortir des bracelets
électroniques rohff
ça marcherait ça si c'était vous j'en
mettrais ce que ça marcherait faudrait
je m'entendais que ministère et puis un
jour j'ai été autorisé à enlever le
bracelet électronique en regard une
nouvelle vie après 17 mois pour demeurer
fleix aujourd'hui 3 novembre on va leur
tirer sous vos yeux on voit le décompte
hockey dix neuf huit sept
six cinq quatre trois deux un zéro
et
c'est reparti qu'on 46 ans semble moins
illégal semble
hélas comme on vient de le voir vous
revenez dans le jeu avec un nouvel album
qui s'appelle rose gueï c'est le
huitième album que vous faites on
regarde à quoi ça ressemble je n'aime
belle et son fond de teint je suis pas
un saint et je m'appelle pas femmes
d'âge parce que bien qu'elle pourra
compter ce n'est pas le type de relation
et ce qu'on dit mais sur moi tu peux
compter tu veux me qui avions de chasse
de perdu dix de piloter pour tout
changement et plancha bien chaude et tu
rêves comme de méchants club france
porter ta main
bijoux c'est le premier single du nouvel
album de rohff qui s'appellera of games
voilà bien une que j'adore manigat
mayrhuber à la vous appelez les noirs
les arabes à ne pas se diviser vous
faites référence aux tranchées pendant
la guerre de 14-18 tous les mecs étaient
ensemble et vous dites nos communautés
sont dans le même bateau
noda rond dans la même usine nos
familles dans le même ghetto n'offre
héros dans les mêmes combines le destin
dans le même et tous et géo ses robes
euros nous adaptons un des trois
peut-être haïr comme te sauver la vie
sans les trois à la france n'a pas
d'avenir c'est vachement bien bordeaux
ronaldinho
alors le même jour le 4 décembre 2015
sont sortis votre album celui de nec feu
julitte jules et suite booba j'en ai
tous là dans les ventes les enfants moi
je suis à
20 mille cinq cents premières semaines
la différence avec booba si vous êtes ce
qu'on appelle un longue c'est la jao
vendée sur une longue période je fais
une passe de neymar une course de fond
cheval faisait pas de mec qui va vendre
dans une semaine et puis ensuite on perd
80 % du chiffre on va la semaine genre
tu vends 40000 ou 50 millions en
deuxième semaine devant 5000 rien ouais
c'est pour ça que vous avez vendu 2
millions d'albums voilà et j'achète pas
mais disent que non plus vous pensez que
booba il fait htc 10 par des potes côté
quand vous êtes devant adele coldplay
ouais justin bieber pendant un mois et
que vous n'avez pas de radio pas 2 à 1
comme on fait des promos et pardon est
une c'est comme ça il fait acheter des
10 permet mais perso je suis persuadé
elle maison de disques le savant booba a
tendance à bien bien expliqué
[Musique]
à belga
est-ce que c'est noël noël est ce que
vous feriez la paix avec booba pour noël
pour noël
jésus non moi je suis je fais ma vie et
ça se passe entre mon public et moi
[Musique]
g
qu'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant à
passer à la face cachée de rohff on va
faire une interview bisounours
ça fait du bien ça va apaiser le débat
et c'est noël tous c'est quoi votre
couleur préférée
le noir est votre fleur préférée celle
que geoffroy ma femme la rose
c'est un sentiment
découvre en europe on connaît pas avec
mon airplay ce géant faire du muguet
c'est quoi pour vous la soirée idéale à
c'est gênant répond pas
lâche moi je mange pas de ce pain là
c'est pas le pain qui va moins je veux
soir idéal c'est quoi c'est pour me
faire sur mon gtoi pommes de terre les
murs
de terre de boue borne est plus faible
que prévu
la chose la plus romantique que vous
ayez faite dans votre vie rohff
il a offert un bracelet électronique
comment c'est ça notre homme sait quand
j'ai fait la demande en mariage ouais à
l'aéroport arrêt au steward
quand vous étiez petit votre doudou
c'était quoi je n'avais pas un pas de
deux
tanks et qui était plein d'eau quand
tu as beaucoup joué en kaki et beaucoup
est-ce que
[Rires]
c'est laurent ma vie mesdames messieurs
est ce que vous êtes désespéré par la
disparition des ours polaires et des
pandas
non non
faites vous un bi zoua les eaux que
c'est beau
m
il
et
maintenant mais monsieur g
[Applaudissements]
non
non ma vie
[Applaudissements]
ça va le nom
super bien ça fait plaisir que moi moi
aussi et toujours marrant c'est quand on
se retrouve on est content mais oui
c'est comme si on s'était quittés la
veille ses fins alors l'an toujours dans
votre fameuse collection des bouquins
sans prétention conçu pour être mis sur
une table basse ou aux toilettes aux
toilettes lui est publié le dictionnaire
des noms propres ou presque chez quéro
laurent c'est vrai qu'à priori aux
toilettes on va pas bien belle du
seigneur ou alors ça veut dire qu'on a
des problèmes de transit mais oui bien
sûr c'est qu'ils se trouvent aux boucles
bah oui parce que ça tombe sous la main
c'est drôle c'est malin pas je suis et
puis ça chez toi
dans ce dictionnaire vous intéresser aux
amas g ouais alors c'est votre côté
second empire les anagrammes c'est un
truc ouais c'est un vieux projet j'en
parlais déjà à l'époque tout le monde en
parle et à l'époque je me souviens
c'était après les clefs de bagnole ouais
tu m'avais dit je vais faire un livre
sur les anagrammes et je t'avais répondu
encore dessus le fréquent à succès mais
il se trouve que c'est un succès voilà
comme quoi
alors 12 55
alain chabat avec les mêmes lettres on
peut écrire habitat canal femme
extraordinaire c'est presque
prémonitoire ces fouilles à la pompe
pour lesquels c'est extraordinaire il y
en a pour qui c'est c'est pas du tout le
propos des trucs et albert einstein par
exemple c'est la plus troublante c'est
la vienne est établie
c'est le mec qui a fait la relativité
c'est la plus troublante c'est de la
folie
nadine morano est un peu démodé parce
que c'est mon 1 adoré ouais ouais c'est
d'ailleurs plus personne à bord le non
non non alors nafissatou diallo l'a 1 ca
deaux fait sa loi
saidal mais c'est dément pas eric
zemmour j'aime les arabes
mais je peux poser une question par
exemple quand un non non non on trouve
plein d'un accueil mais pas comme s'il y
avait une sauce et n'ont pu faire serait
une seule vie après tu choisis on
travaille avec des générateurs d'un à g
voilà mais ils peuvent sortir deux mille
possibilités après fautrier remettre les
mots dans l'ordre mais tout le monde
peut faire ça et j'encourage tout le
monde à faire ça ne serait ce que pour
la famille on peut trouver des pépites
extraordinaire 1 c'est génial thierry
ardisson balle roi tyran d'hier
c'est dingue le commandant cousteau tout
commença dans l'eau ah ouais
c'est dingue bon après il y en a qui
sont pas tellement avantageuse moi
j'aime beaucoup marion cotillard 1 mais
heureusement ça donne [ __ ] mal arrondi
on choisit pas
ouais
quel boulot ouais mais je travaille déjà
sur le prochain le prochain c'est les
petites annonces qu'ils annoncent façon
pierre dac voilà leur visite et ouais
gode ceinture écoeurés par certaines
pratiques cherche place de porte manteau
dans chambre d'enfant
[Applaudissements]
et bien qu un
an le théâtre évidemment sans filtre au
théâtre fontaine et caroline anglade et
pascal sellem berline anglade qui
accouchent bientôt qui était remplacé
par lola marois bigard lahouel jean
marie pascal sellem jean-noël brouté qui
arrive cinq lectrices
qu'est ce que tu fais non je suis très
fécond je suis très fier dit très fécond
ça marche ça cartonne on va fêter la
300e la semaine prochaine à trois
centièmes
[Musique]
on passe maintenant au dossier de la
semaine avec désintox et si le
sociologue et écrivain frédéric lenoir
que nous accueillerons sur ce plateau
après le magnéto désintox de ce soir
jésus
[Musique]
aujourd'hui jésus est devenu une star
internationale alors forcément s'il
revenait sur terre tout le monde le
reconnaîtra au premier coup d'oeil avec
sa barre sa tunique ses sandales et sa
couronne d'épinés pas moyen de le rater
s'il revenait aujourd'hui en france il
serait accueilli comme une star invité
sur tous les plateaux télé jésus est
avec nous ce soir
reçu en grande pompe à l'elysée et il
remplirait facilement le stade de france
pour chacun de ses meetings
en fait si jésus rabelais est ce que
vous croyez vraiment que ça se passerait
comme ça faut pas oublier que la
dernière fois que jésus est venu sur
terre ça s'est très mal fini si on veut
imaginer à quoi ressemblerait le retour
de jésus faut adapter le récit des
évangiles à la france d'aujourd'hui
selon les évangiles mes parents de jésus
étaient des migrants en effet joseph et
marie ont dû quitter leurs maisons sous
la pression des troupes romaines qui
occupaient la palestine
c'est pour ça que jésus est né dans une
étable
si jésus né sait aujourd'hui en france
se ferait un enfant de migrants et il
aurait très bien pu naître dans la
jungle de calais alors vous croyez qu'on
accueillerait à bras ouverts à l'âge
adulte jésus a continué de vivre comme
un sdf dans les évangiles il
recommandait ses disciples le vendre
tous leurs biens pour le suivre sur la
route toute la sainte journée en faisant
la manche d'un village à l'autre autant
dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya pas mal de
quoi en france où jésus aurait les flics
sur le dos toute la journée d'autant que
jésus passé son temps à haranguer les
foules
et comme il parlait bien sacré des
attroupements si jésus revenait
aujourd'hui faut donc imaginer un sdf
barbu qui tiendrait des discours d'
illuminé à propos de la fin du monde qui
approche orbach de crever pas tous comme
la fin du monde nous attend et nous
emmène après tout le temps autant dire
qu'une seule idée de nos jours en france
jésus serait sans doute assigné à
résidence avec un bracelet électronique
est inscrit au fichier s faut dire que
jésus était un radical
au chapitre 5 de son évangile mathieu
raconte que jésus était parfois si ta
main droite tu entraînes à commettre des
péchés mieux vaut la coupe et la jeter
loin de poids plutôt que de finir en
enfer alors vous croyez que jésus serait
bien accueilli s'il revenait parmi nous
voilà c'était désintox signé blaco nous
en images de juniac grand
blond soir d'être
écrivain j'ai publié de nombreux lits
dont le dernier la puissance de la joie
publié chez fayard cartonne vraiment en
librairie bienvenue parmi nous le noir
le noir je présente alors frédéric jésus
révolutionnaire
c'est vrai que jésus s'est octroyé une
liberté radical par rapport à la torah
et par rapport aux shabbat absolument
alors si vous prenez le triptyque
républicain liberté égalité fraternité
tout est déjà dans l'évangile liberté
parce qu'il me permet au leap aux
individus de s'émanciper du groupe
égalité parce qu'il prône une égalité de
tous les êtres humains il ya plus de
différences entre les juifs les
non-juifs les grecs entre les esclaves
et les hommes libres entre les hommes et
les drames égalité tous les abcès
révolutionnaire c'est totalement
révolutionnaire et fraternité ouais donc
le troisième message c'est tous les
êtres humains sont tous frères et donc
évidemment c'est un message d'appel à la
tolérance et la non violence alors c'est
vrai que le leit motiv de jésus c'est
l'amour du prochain il faudrait pas non
plus en faire un
utopiste genre peace and love et tout ça
parce que il dit à un moment ce que je
veux c'est pas la paix mais l'épée alors
faut comprendre cette phrase c'est la
seule phrase entre guillemets qui paraît
violentes dans les évangiles le contexte
c'est que il ya quelqu'un qui veut le
suivre et les parents s'opposent à ce
que ses 17 enfants suivent jésus et il
dit je suis venu appeler n'ont pas
apporté la paix mais le glaive sert à
séparer les parents des enfants là le
fils du du père la fille de la mère
c'est à dire je suis appelé à convertir
les individus au delà de leurs liens
familiaux et tribaux et donc ça veut
dire que la liberté individuelle est
plus forte que le lien communautaire
c'est ça que ça veut dire s'il revenait
aujourd'hui lors des problèmes avec la
brigade des moeurs mais laissez venir à
moi les petits enfants
alors est ce que jésus est né le 25
décembre a en fait les premiers
chrétiens ont fait coïncider
la naissance de jésus avec la fête
païenne en fête du solstice d'hiver mais
toute façon jésus il voulait pas
tellement qu'on commémore sa naissance
il aurait préféré qu'on commémore sa
mort ce qui est sacrificielle ouais
c'est vrai c'est vrai car on sait pas du
tout quand jésus est né et donc le 25
décembre c'est la fête du soleil
renaissance et la fête païenne du soleil
qui renonce et les jours qu'elle
recommence à voile à s'arrondir donc
c'est un symbole en fait donc nul ne
sait quand jésus est né et il vous avez
raison ce le plus important pour lui
pour les chrétiens d'ailleurs c'est la
fête de pâques c'est à dire que c'est à
la fois la mort et la résurrection sûr
c'est la foi chrétienne fondamentale
elle est là dessus alors jésus était-il
hommes ou de dieu alors pour ses
disciples c'était un homme
extraordinaire capable de miracles
ressuscité par dieu mais le caractère
divin jésus en fait arrive cent ans plus
tard tardivement voilà à peu près 100
ans après sa mort on commence à trouver
déjà dans l'évangile de jean qui a été
écrit très longtemps après après nuit
l'idée qu' il peut être plus qu'un homme
mais l'incarnation de dieu et ce au 4e
siècle au concile de nicée que ça va
devenir un dogme officiel ça que la foi
chrétienne repose sur cette idée là il à
la fois homme et dieu ça l'a éloigné des
gens nagent après que les humains le
jésus hommes move c'est ce que je pense
mais ça n'engage que moi je pense que
jésus lui même ne savait pas qui il
était ouais c'était il était une énigme
pour lui-même rohff vous aimer jésus
comme tous les prophètes les musulmans
reconnaissent jésus bien sûr il a fait
tout ça voilà les seuls à considérer
comme un profil est très élevé auprès de
dieu il n'ya pas de filiation divine il
est comme tous les problèmes titre que
tous les autres prophètes voilà
l'exemple même fréquentent nos liens qui
entre deux et dix la guider ses plus
célèbres malheureusement ni laisser le
politique aujourd'hui c'est le politique
c'est voilà c'est un conflit culturel et
de civilisation lié à tout aimé la toise
mais la base c'est un lien intrinsèque
voilà juste chrétiens musulmans sont
dans un socle comme quoi la disons le ce
soir et puis il ya quelque chose de dons
n'a pas parlé mais moi qui me touche
énormément c'est que l'évangile est
habité par la joie c'est le thème majeur
ben c'est le thème de votre livre donc
qui s'appelle la puissance de la joie
chez fayard et c'est vrai que jésus a
dit il y a plus de joie à donner qu'à
recevoir et le pape françois rey c'est
ça qui est extraordinaire
a plus envie de toucher les lakers avec
l'amour que faire des discours
moralisateurs parce que l'église souvent
apparaît comme une puissance
moralisatrice le pape françois illy
vraiment il est vrai millet dans
l'évangile à il parfait mais j'ai fait
il ya deux ans un livre sur le pape
françois quelques mois après son
élection en disant c'est un miracle que
les cardinaux conservateur moralisateur
tout était lui un pape antique l'élan
qu'il semble pas qu'il leur ressemble à
un anticlérical qui dit carrément on va
dans le mur parce que on tourne le dos à
l'évangile l'évangile c'est pas
d'interdire aux homosexuels aux divorcés
remariés d'aller commune et celle
inverse jésus lui ai dit je suis venu
pour les pêcheurs succès loin de tout et
donc finalement c'est exactement la mère
de ce café l'église est ce qui fait que
ce qui est le coeur du message de
l'évangile c'est que les êtres humains
ne vont pas changer par là simplement
par la volonté par la raison parce qu'on
leur dit c'est mal il faut changer ça
c'est la morale jésus lui dit non ça
marche pas on va changer uniquement
parce qu'on touche le coeur des gens
merci fred m merci
[Musique]
ouais
frédéric merci d'avoir été avec nous
long d'un fil merci d'avoir un calembour
et voilà c'était la pub 2-2 celle qui en
sortent soit près d'un bus avec le
zapping guillon et notre terriens du
sénateur ce soir ludwig brillant at an
après le cri entend notamment la bbc qu
il viendra nous raconter ce qu'il est
devenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir tél non mon sens hyper sommes de
retour sur terre toujours en compagnie
de virginie efira
géraldine nakache
et l'europe
et nous accueillons notre cas rien du
samedi 20 heures ce soir ludwig brillant
voudrions bonsoir
revient de 20 ans vous étiez mimi siku
un indien dans la ville
si si regardez et voilà c'est lui ce
rôle culte du cinéma français à effet de
vous un enfant star mais vingt ans plus
tard vous êtes complètement sorti du
star system vous êtes greffier stagiaire
au tribunal de bobigny chacun sa route
chacun son chemin
chacun sait rien chacun son chemin
c'est message à ton voisin
vous nous raconterez votre histoire à 20
heures mais d'abord le zapping
c'était le zapping jusqu'ici tout allait
bien voici stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
on commence avec l'info de la semaine le
front national ne gagne aucune région
zéro pointé ils font chier
à chaque fois ils nous feront qu il
termine premier au premier tour et après
s'écroule nous on se prépare on se met
en condition on sait qu'on va devoir
sortir de l'europe fermer les frontières
retourner au franc ont fait des
provisions n'achète de l'huile du sucre
un berger allemand on s'entraîne à
marcher au pas de l'oie à respecter le
couvre-feu on se met à la culture bleu
marine on achète un dvd de jean roucas
le dernier zemmour
en fait le maximum pour être prêts ils
perdent ils font chier
marine le pen y publie sur son compte
twitter des photos d'otages exécutés par
des chefs
en réponse à jean jacques bourdin qui a
comparé l'état islamique au fn ou très
par le procédé des ch a aussitôt publié
des photos de marine le pen
ah non c'est immonde cet ignoble non non
non c'est dégueulasse qua non non ils
n'ont plus aucune limite d'âge
[Applaudissements]
lors de son retour en politique nicolas
sarkozy nous avait juré avoir changé
être plus à l'écouté des autres accepter
la critique le débat et ce même nicolas
sarkozy a éjecté nathalie kosciusko
morizet sous prétexte qu'elle
n'approuvait pas son nid
c'est vrai que j'ai changé
je prends des avis j'écoute et permettez
moi de vous dire thierry ardisson que
quand il ya eu un débat sur le choix de
la machine à café au siège des
républicains certains préféraient les
capsules les senso un les capsules
souple et d'autre les durs les nespresso
on a choisi très calme et la dignité et
paris pour le canapé il y avait un camp
orange beaubois est un comme monsieur
meuble
en revanche il ya dix ans quand il
s'agit de gouverner le pays de prendre
des décisions graves là c'est une
affaire d'hommes j'accepterai aucune
contradiction et madame morizet 1 et que
ses cheveux oranges saisir de mylène
farmer du pauvre d'yvette horner de
prisunic elle rentre dans le rang ou
elle dégage
sinon pour le reste il ya dix ans je
suis à l'écouté
j'ai changé
sur le plateau de l'émission c'est à
vous jean pierre bacri a clashé eric
zemmour le qualifiant de mike horn pour
les nuls
zemmour e zemmour ça fait un moment que
je voulais me le faire cesser cette
brute il acquit qui méprise les femmes
comme comme comme c'est pas permis et
qui qui qui qui dit que la planète c'est
la cuisine en
2015 un kit imagine le pauvre type wall
alan la misère à malanje et d'en avoir
une toute petite
tenir des propos pareils quoi zemmour
qui a écrit que pétain à à sauver des
juifs bientôt il va nous dire que hitler
célébrer chaque bateau ça ça non mais
moi moi ça veut ça me fatigue audace je
me fous qu'il existe ce gratte papiers
de 2,2 de deux douzaines
jeu ça me débecte rangement en tirer je
le dis ça ça me débecte
télévision après 27 ans de bons et
loyaux services
julien lepers évincé de questions pour
un champion
bien sûr mais oui mais c'est une
connerie c'est une connerie les
personnes âgées elles ont des repères
télévisuelle hyper précis claire chazal
c'était le week-end julien lepers la
semaine là ils vont êtres paumés chez
des personnes âgées chaque présentateur
à sa fonction jean pierre pernaut à 13h
ils les inquiète il les fait voter à
droite ensuite les feux de l'amour ça
les fait rêver ça excite les plus
vaillants julien lepers leur fait
travailler la mémoire et puis le soir
mimie mathy ange gardien ça les endort
ah oui non non non non non non même
diminué le vieux garde toute sa tête et
sans que c'est nul ils se réfugient dans
le sommeil supprimer lepers c'est une
connerie
[Applaudissements]
question pour un champion c'est une
émission culte ça ouvre l'esprit ça
permet d'apprendre des tas de choses
oui oui oui oui oui thierry thierry
thierry
les séries les guerriers du crès thierry
vous êtes prêts 1 à 10 un indice qui
s'affiche là tout de suite chez vous à
la maison attention c'est un outil rita
régis une politique j'appartiens aux
républicains mais je viens d'être élu en
surfant sur les thèses du front national
notamment en inscrivant sur mes affiches
immigration ça suffit je porte une parka
rouge ridicule et je regardais porno sur
youporn je suis je suis je suis bon ok
[Applaudissements]
c'est physique
indirects passé sur [ __ ] je comprends
pourquoi ils s'arrêtent gérard holtz
aussi s'arrête très
mobilisés bout bon
lopez à ces cons je connaissais deux
personnes qui regardent et
faits divers deux morts dans le crash
d'un hélicoptère en argentine lors du
tournage de l'émission de télé réalité
the challenge c'est minable mines amina
ben pour le tournage de deux drops
qu'elle dit mort quand on fait un remake
faut s'appliquer si c'est pour faire
moins bien c'est pas la peine
une fois n'est pas coutume on termine
cette chronique avec une affaire
judiciaire
en angleterre un promoteur immobilier a
accusé de viol s'est défendu en
prétextant avoir trébuché j'ai trébuché
at il dit est gelée pénétrait par
accident
dsk a tenu à nous expliquer ce phénomène
peu connu
la pénétration par accident qu est ce
que c
est l hôtel digue est en plein jet lag
et au lieu de prendre de la mélatonine
pour tenir le coup pour tromper de
pilules
bonnet du viagra
et à ce moment là une solution l'eau
froide la douche me lire mener à tout
prix manque de bol la salle de bain bien
être fait ça glisse vous appelez la
femme de chambre pour vous plaindre et
là le drame le drame thierry effrayés
par vaux proportion elle s'enfuit recul
et trébuche tenter l'impossible à
rattraper éviter qu'elle se blesse et
vous glisser aussi tenté de reculer
marche arrière et vous réglez c'est ben
il vient infernale
qui n'en finit plus c'est la pénétration
par accident d'hier dix ans
qui touche à travers le monde des
centaines de voyageurs innocent un
véritable fléau je vais le noël à tous
et n'oubliez pas n'oubliez pas le petit
jésus dans la crèche à très bientôt
merci
non
[Applaudissements]
limitrophe et voilà on passe maintenant
à notre terre du samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
dit vick brillant rebond soir
vous êtes line 9 mai
1981 à soisy sous montmorency dans le
val d'oise père chauffagiste mère
puéricultrice alors quand votre tante
inscrire vos cousins dans l' agence
bout'chou votre mère vous y inscrire
aussi et dès l'âge de 9 ans vous
commencez à passez vous vos premiers
castings toutes avaient
alors premiers rôles vous lisez des
poèmes à des chiens ouais enfin moi
j'avais lu un poème c'est ma première
apparition télé c'était ça
à partir de là vous passez vous mercredi
après milliers à faire des castings mais
votre rêve en fait c'est de devenir
batteur pour vous un batteur c'est le
top d'abord parce qu'il a les cheveux
longs
et ensuite parce qu'il a une batterie
mais comme aux parents n'ont pas les
moyens de vous offrir une batterie vous
contenter d'avoir les cheveux longs
ouais ouais il ya ça et puis ma mère a
aussi tenait ce que j'ai selon elle
l'aimé beaucoup mais celle où le bien
est un jour vous êtes sur scène à
mogador pour un énième casting ans et le
casting de la dernière chance ainsi sa
marche pas vous arrêter un vous êtes
sélectionné pour jouer gavroche dans les
misérables alors après les misérables à
mogador les castings s'enchaînent fait
un clip avec renault oui petit voleur
tout à fait identique emmanuelle béart
fait un clip avec eddy mitchell aussi
ouais alors quand vous êtes sélectionnés
pour le premier rôle de l'instit vous
refusez de vous couper les cheveux sur
le coup je dis oui puis après je
rappelle financera pas
bien nous en a pris parce que quelques
mois plus tard la directrice de casting
qui doit trouver le premier rôle de han
dans la vie le rôle de mimi siku se
souvient de vos cheveux longs elle vous
appelle au départ la production voulait
un guyanais ouais je fasse que m'a
raconté c'est ce qui me racontait à
hervé palud le réalisateur qui à la base
ils ont fait beaucoup de recherches
ouais là bas pour avoir un mais ils ont
pas trouvé voilà hervé palud a dit si
c'est pas lui je fais pas le film quand
il m'a rencontrée il a su que c'était
moi et tout de suite si c'était pas faim
qu'il avait trouvé son amiens et que
voilà si ce n'était pas moi ce que
j'aimerais être là pendant six mois pour
préparer un indien dans la ville vous
faites de la gymnastique fait de l'
escalade
vous apprenez le le tir à l'arc mais je
faisais des séances de tir à l'arc j'ai
même j'ai passé en fait on passe un des
niveaux au tir à l'arc et ma flèche
blanche crois que ça s'appelle je les
passais mois avec un arc d'indiens pour
le coup
voilà et donc ce qu'il faut dire quand
même c'est que dans l'indien dans la
ville ces scènes absolument vertigineuse
sont réalisés sans aucun trucage en fait
rien n'était fait en studio en tout cas
on regarde
[Musique]
ouais
alors
autre difficulté mimi siku chasse le
serpent à sarbacane les oiseaux avec un
arc et il se balade avec mighty kg
mygale apprivoiser tu as fait une terra
faisable on dit exactement on regarde
[Musique]
aujourd'hui beaucoup y ait beaucoup les
shows doit avoir peur c'est quoi
couillet
après c'est le coach
extraordinaires
les uns scène la plus dure à tourner
pour vous ça a été d'embrasser la petite
parisienne à la fin du film quoi c'est
facile à évaluer votre vie cocaïne
en quelques semaines un indien dans la
ville avec thierry lhermitte arielle
dombasle miu miu et patrick timsit et
vous écrase la concurrence 8 millions de
spectateurs c'est un succès énorme
succès mondial
faites votre tournée et toute l'équipe
l'allemagne l'espagne l'italie la suède
taiwan le japon vous montez les marches
au festival de cannes il vous fait nulle
part ailleurs elle m'avait fait venir en
indien en pagne et j'avais fait la météo
à l'époque je n'ai eu une énorme star
tous les gosses dans la cour de récré
rejouer les scènes du film d'expression
qui évidemment ont fait le tour de
france et ouakka tp baboune
[Rires]
[Musique]
et voilà quelques années voilà
alors malgré le succès vous garder les
pieds sur terre vous la seule chose que
vous demandez en fait dans les hôtels
cédés table ronde ouais je pille et les
hôtels ya toujours deux tours le frigo
et 1 c'est vrai deux ans après l'indien
vous faites deux téléfilms et après le
bac vous choisissez quand même de
revenir vers le droit ouais drainant des
études de droit à l'université de cergy
pontoise
parallèlement fait des petits boulots
comme tout le monde vous êtes un des
inventaires vous êtes reaper l'orgue
reaper savoir c'est quelqu'un qui
déplace les décors sur les plateaux
animateur de centre de loisirs et père
noël al'avantage de père noël c'est que
personne ne vous reconnais évidemment
d'abord une fête du poker ouais sous le
nom de mimi siku 95 ouais je serais
champion d'île de france et vous
participerez aux championnats du monde à
las vegas tout à fait ouais c'est bien
mais gégé et puis pour le coup j'ai
battu laurent baffie pour le coup parce
qu'il faisait partie des people qui est
invité à aussi à participer ce type de
verre
le problème c'est que le poker ne nous
fait pas vivre non non non à vous
devenez vendeurs experts en cigares dans
des boutiques de duty free à roissy
ouais t'as fait tout le boulot ma vie
même et et bonimenteurs hausse puisqu'on
parlait de marché de noël j'ai fait
aussi sa démarche est tout fait quoi
vicié d'intégrer des cours de théâtre à
l'époque mais ça se passe pas bien vous
d'essayer de revenir vers des
professions juridiques et aujourd'hui
donc vous êtes ludovic stagiaires
greffier au tribunal de grande instance
de bobigny en ce moment je suis en stage
à bobigny mais sinon je suis à l'école
nationale des greffes en fête à dijon et
là je vais choisir mon poste dans mois
de janvier ah ouais alors que reste-t-il
de cette aventure au début vous touchiez
plus que maintenant chaque fois que le
film passe à la télé vous toucher 50
euros et puis vous avez à chaque fois
que le film passe 100 demandes d'amis
sur facebook ouais en fait en général je
regarde pas spécialement les diffusions
mais je suis à plus ou moins informés
par rapport au nombre sur twitter sur
tout le monde cette année avec vous je
suis pas mais ça déclencherait des je
comprends j'aimerais bien être
jadot
[Musique]
chacun savait tiens 15 ans
mais
voilà c'était sa limite à votre tour
vous samedi soir avec virginie efira
geraghty
la casse laurent 26
elle freiner
noir
non merci beaucoup merci à tous ceux qui
m'ont aidé à faire cette émission salut
les terriens
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux